welcome back to cbs mornings the lion
state of queen elizabeth continues in
london her children and grandchildren
will stand watch tonight while mourners
file past the coffin the line stretching
from westminster hall is estimated five
miles long this morning a few hours ago
officials stopped people from joining
the line saying it was completely full
holly williams is watching the
preparations for monday's funeral
good morning well the united kingdom has
plenty of experience organizing
elaborate public events
from the funeral of princess diana to
royal weddings all require meticulous
preparation but this is reportedly the
most complex security operation london's
ever seen with around 10 000 police
officers and 1500 military personnel
already deployed the queen's funeral
will be held here at westminster abbey
in the heart of london filled with
historic buildings and narrow streets
the abbey sits just across the road from
the british houses of parliament just
down the road from the prime minister's
residence number 10 downing street and a
stone's throw from london's crowded
shopping and entertainment district the
west end that's where two police
officers were stabbed and hospitalized
just this morning the mayor said it was
not terrorism related
president biden and dr jill biden will
attend the funeral along with many of
the crowned heads of europe the japanese
emperor and of course the uk's own royal
family
one british official likened the
logistics of the queen's funeral to
organizing a hundred state visits all at
the same time
nate
that was holly williams in london thank
you gail and norah o'donnell will lead
our coverage of queen elizabeth funeral
on monday morning starting at 5 30
eastern time looking forward to that